こんにちははじめ社長です ed 雪
1週間生活が終わりません
[拍手]
ありがとうございますそんな滅相もない人もない癒したいそうだとしておりませんあの
通れば9ゲームで自立と1週間来なきゃいけなくなったんですけれども
まあちゃんと理由ず凝視やろうと思いまして罰ゲームと言ってもギリースーツ1週間
キューブいろいろわかることがあるのではないかなと思いました
そもそも夏はにキュリー刹那明日はどんなものなのだろうか
どうぞの姿を隠すため掛け流出
そ日常に切るとどれくらい貼れなくなるのかあの北松戸ターレット結構なやかや
あの声をかけていただけるんでこれいると意外と声をかけられないんじゃねーかな
みんなが見えないんじゃねぇかなと思ったりしております
しておりましたというわけでえと1週間肌に話さずめる時とお袋がいる時が基本的に常
にデリズときたまま1週間生活してみました
それではご覧くださいと思う
[音楽]
ございます
5日目です天をも吸収するんですよねイレースって歩けないねぇ
るっ
田岡大魔王
パロった桜
power dj ren and car with me
i am
アブダメですね聞かれるとこだった
阿部社長や近くにいる側からするともうちょっと見慣れちゃったあー見慣れちゃった
けどねぇて内閣
気付いてないからかもしれませんいないことに慣れさせるそう
[拍手]
を悪くないねぇ
ni
[拍手]
[音楽]
持っています
me
[音楽]
俺が見えてるだと
はいというわけでいかがだったでしょうか
あっを打つんだかメッシュみたいになってるんですけどもそれでもちょっと熱いぜ後
切りちょっと来てない時よりキレた時の方が
みんなに声をかけられるようになりますけどねぇ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ